hey guys it's Chris Kohler with game
life game developers conference has
officially kicked off the first session
is a keynote from Microsoft corporate
vice president John Shepherd now the
rumor is that he's going to talk about
Gears of War 2 so let's go check it out
thanks Jamil for that kind introduction
now at Xbox I believe it's our mission
to do everything we can to break down
the barrier between the creators all of
you and the consumers first it'll take
the democratization of game development
and it'll also take something else the
democratization of game distribution
today I'm incredibly excited to announce
for the first time ever this year you'll
be able to have community games
distributed through Xbox Live and it's a
simple process create submit review and
play now ten million people on Xbox Live
get to play your game this is of right
now you could go to Xbox Live
Marketplace and you can download a free
trial of dishwasher a little game as a
jello car and four other great community
games get on life get these games and
start experiencing what the community
can do because it will amaze you so it's
been about a year and a half since we've
made Gears of War launched at holiday oh
six but we've been pretty busy since
that eighteen months ago when we
launched the game we've had a lot of
awesome new features for the Unreal
Engine and we've really optimized it for
the Xbox 360
sweet
now I want to tell you that gears one
was a setup it was an appetizer for all
the characters the environments the
gameplay mechanics we introduced in the
first gears to is going to be bigger
better and far more badass than the
first game in every way and today I'm
proud to tell you
Gears of War 2 will be available
exclusively on Xbox 360 this November
thanks for your time guys I'm gonna go
kill some locust enjoy the rest of GDC
Microsoft Vice President John Shaffer
just finished up his keynote here at
Game Developers Conference and while for
a lot of people the big news has got to
be Gears of War 2 coming this holiday
season this November it's gonna be huge
for me I'm mostly interested in Xbox
Live Arcade and the user-created games
that are gonna start becoming available
well right now Microsoft wants to get
there they seem to want to get hundreds
of different games created by indie game
developers garage game developers up on
Xbox Live Arcade there's a peer review
process and then you know users will be
able to you know to try all kinds of
different new games and actually if you
turn on your Xbox 360 right now you can
go play them so I would say go check
those out
you